we've already had four interest rate
cuts since last November has not really
sparked the economy despite the
aberrations we got in the first half
with that stock market bubble and also
we've had several cuts to the reserve
ratio requirements at the banks they
still have a lot of room to go there ANZ
Bank for one expects at least another
benchmark interest rate cut the key
issue bachana can they accelerate
productivity growth rates in a domestic
economy externally facing China is
already competitive it's really
agriculture services domestic industries
and when I talk about domestic reform I
don't mean combining a couple of
shipping companies what you need to look
at is over 10,000 state-owned
enterprises across China how can you
improve productivity of that area what
you should look at is agriculture one of
the very few areas where China is less
competitive than India is actually in
agriculture there's been a bit of a race
to the bottom out here with Japan
obviously depreciating its currency the
Euro obviously has been weaker and we
saw this reflected in the monthly export
numbers as you mentioned your exports
were down eight point three percent much
more than expected EU shipments down
2.5% Japanese shipments to Japan down
ten and a half percent
what we have heard in recent months are
rumblings from senior leaders that they
will finally turn their attention to
state-owned enterprise reform this is
known to be a high on the policy agenda
for the leadership so this sort of seems
to be a new step in that I mean the big
thing to remember on the SOS is they
dominate so much of the economy so if
the government is looking for areas
where it can spur growth as well as
allowing increased lending by policy
banks and some of the other measures you
guys mentioned SOE reform sort of
tightening them up making them more
efficient would be a natural next step
yeah the way I look at it are you your
son of selecting amongst ugly sisters
there are problems everywhere so would
you rather buy commodity producers are
rather than commodity consumers would
you rather buy countries that are
dependent on a foreign capital flows I
would you rather buy a country that has
significant domestic liquidity so we
select chart and not because China
doesn't have a problem China has many
problems it just everybody else also
have very substantial problems going
forward